well the pandemic forced most of us to
put our lives on hold for the last year
but for children fighting cancer there
are no days off no it's a lot of work
especially for their families too and
fundraising for critical research to
help these kids can't afford to take any
time out either st baldrick's foundation
raises millions of dollars to help find
cures for childhood cancers by shaving
heads to raise money sherry talked to a
local couple who have been involved for
years yes they have and you know
normally heather and john we see a lot
of shaved heads this time of year in the
springtime both men and women and that's
in the month of march but the pandemic
forced mcmullen's irish pub to postpone
their huge annual hair raising event
this year until now i spoke with lynn
and brian mcmullen about how the event
will look different this year
normally we'd be doing this in march
but it's it's september so tell me about
the changes with the event this year
we have an event this saturday running
from noon till about 8 pm and it's going
to be a little different in so far as we
will
mandate mosques inside and we will keep
the crowd in shenaniganz a little
smaller as we typically
jam that room up elbow to our bodies
a lot sleeker i love the way you
described it lynn as shenanigans
[Applause]
but all these families are there
together and friends it's such a support
system uh but brian talk about how many
people do you expect that will be there
this weekend at mcmullens to get their
heads shaved we probably have about
sixty percent i would imagine of what we
normally would have we've we'll raise
over a quarter of a million
it's not a half a million like we
normally do but it should beats zero
sure
some broaddricks is in the need of money
because lots of events have been
cancelled throughout the
country and we
are grateful for all the las vegas who
come there
and
give their hard-earned money to this
wonderful cause for people who don't
know your story can you talk about your
inspiration for doing this and your
daughter and why you do this year after
year after year
sherry thank you for asking you know the
most critical question of all
um essentially my t-shirt says team cara
our daughter's name is cairo we have
three children akara was our middle
child she was diagnosed with a brain
tumor when she was one
and we lived in denver at the time
and she passed away when she was two and
a half ten years later her tumor was
diagnosed as a different type of tumor
and i feel like parents like us when
this diagnosis comes to your family um
you definitely want the best arsenal
that you can
to fight the best fight that you can
and i feel like it's um
there's not a parent in the world that i
think they can't relate to that
and research essentially is how we save
lives so without our story without her
this event we may not be having this
conversation so i believe that
we're just beginning to try to
do the right thing because these kids
need us
all over the world and this research is
fundamental and it becomes
one for these families when research
when money is money to research so
yeah team cairo mcmullen's irish pub
they're very much one of the same and
she's the reason
it all happened in the first place
and so many families can identify with
their story well head shaving at
mcmullens begins at noon that's tomorrow
september 16th september 16th right yeah
no no no no
yes yes yes i don't know that date's
wrong uh and it goes and from noon until
8 pm now you can still sign up on their
website to get shaved or you can watch
virtually they have a twitch account
this year you can donate through that
and you can watch all the fun a lot of
the extras will be outside the pub
you must wear a mask indoors you can
register outdoors they have food
outdoors and we have the links on our
website 8newsnow.com
so all right i apologize for that date i
don't know how that i got that wrong
there in the script but it is tomorrow
saturday from noon to eight
and uh again there'll be plenty of
shenanigans it'll just be downsized
that's all right yeah but you got your
get your clippers uh ready to go well
they they don't trust brian and i to
shave no i'm sorry which is a good thing
i'm sure and brian agree they've usually
got volunteer shavers from salons around
town they do barbers and hair stylists
that come in and do it and everybody is
just so giving and it's just a wonderful
wonderful time tears joy it's a good one
i love it when they spend a little more
money somebody volunteers to shave off
the eyebrows the beer the goatee the
beard yeah it's a good event
i like that they have this the stylists
there they're like so what style would
you like how about everything off
this is all done that's the style right
there but you gotta raise money for each
cut absolutely